there's a great word that I learned
recently called sonder and it means to
be aware of other struggles even though
you don't know what the struggles are so
it's kind of the idea that you could be
sat in the train station you've got all
these people are walking past you and
you just stop for a moment ago all of
these people that walking past me have
challenges in their life they've had
things that have happened things that
might happen things that might be
happening right now someone might have
the worst call of their life and it's
not at all to think like oh I hope other
people are suffering too but it's an
awareness that your own suffering isn't
the only suffering to happen and there's
a sense of like unloading that comes
with that and it's a similar feeling to
when you share a problem